una recta pasa por los puntos menos 16 y
el punto 5 menos 4
cuál es la ecuación de esta recta así
que lo primero que quiero hacer es
graficar a esta recta y los datos que me
dan entonces este es mi eje de las x
este es mi eje de las 10 aquí tengo un
plano cartesiano y el primer punto que
me dan es el menos 16 así que vamos a
dibujar menos 1 en x y 6 en 6 para
arriba entonces tengo este primer punto
después tengo otro punto el 5 como menos
4 este dato también nos dan así que 5 a
la derecha 5 en x y 4 hacia abajo y
tengo este otro punto de aquí y ya que
tengo estos dos puntos entonces voy a
trazar la recta que pasa por ellos y lo
voy a intentar hacer lo mejor posible
tenemos una recta lo mejor posible por
eso lo voy a hacer mejor punteado ya que
tengo esta línea recta punteada ahora sí
para encontrar la ecuación de esta recta
me voy a fijar en qué ecuación de recta
quiero encontrar y para esto quiero
encontrar la cuestión es la recta que es
igual a mx más 20 es decir la ecuación
de la recta de la forma pendiente
ordenada al origen y bueno para esto lo
que me gustaría saber es quién es la
pendiente pero la pendiente es más o
menos que el cambio en x con respecto a
lo que cambia en bien o dicho de otra
manera como la diferencia del valor de
iu en el punto final menos el valor de l
en el punto inicial entre la diferencia
del valor de x en el punto final menos
el valor de x en el punto inicial es
decir esto lo mismo que el cambio de jan
el cambio en x lo podemos ver como el
alza entre el avance es decir el cambio
horizontal entre el cambio vertical o en
dado caso lo podemos ver como ye 2 menos
de 1 esto es el cambio en james es lo
que cambiamos en 10 de un punto al otro
entre x 2 - x 1 que esto es ni más ni
menos que el cambio en x es decir lo que
cambiamos en x de un punto al otro y
bueno pues entonces ya que tengo esta
idea entonces
utilizar esta fórmula para sacar mi
pendiente si yo me fijo en estos dos que
tengo que es lo que voy a encontrar en
primer lugar en el punto inicial y voy a
suponer que este es mi punto inicial
este de aquí estaba situado en el día
igual a 6 y baje hasta aquí en igual a
menos 4 así que de aquí hasta acá
podemos ver que hay una diferencia de 10
unidades es decir del punto inicial al
punto final en james estamos cambiando
10 unidades o sirte sencillamente
podemos sustituir los valores en la
fórmula es decir el punto final en 100
que es menos cuatro menos el punto
inicial en 10 que es 6 recuerda que a
éste fue el que bautizamos como de 2 ya
éste fue que llamamos de 1 y entonces
nos va a quedar menos 46 lo cual son 10
unidades de diferencia en este caso nos
va a quedar menos 10 y todo esto deja de
poner igual a menos 10 y todo esto hay
que dividirlo entre quien bueno entre el
cambio en x pero que es el cambio en x
pues lo que cambie en x desde este valor
que era menos 1 hasta el valor de
5 cuántas unidades hay de menos 1 a 5
pues bueno déjame graficar lo si yo me
fijo en este como x 1 y éste como x 2
entonces cambiando de aquí hasta acá y
son seis unidades fíjate que empezamos
en menos uno caminamos una para llegar
al cero y después cinco hasta llegar al
cinco son seis unidades y si aplicamos
la fórmula por ciento nos va a quedar x
2 - x 1 es decir 5 este es x 2 menos
menos uno que es el valor de x 1 por lo
tanto 5 - menos 1 y bueno 5 - x menos
nada más entonces me queda 5 más 1 de
los cuales 6 y bueno menos 10 sextos es
lo que nos da dependiente que esto lo
podemos simplificar esto es exactamente
lo mismo que menos 5 tercios sacamos
mitad a arriba y sacamos mitad abajo y
perfecto porque ya con esto encontramos
la pendiente ya sabemos al menos que la
pendiente vale menos cinco tercios y
entonces déjame reescribir otra vez esta
ecuación de mi recta me queda y es igual
a menos cinco tercios de x + b lo único
que hice fue sustituir
dependiente y ahora me voy a preguntar
cómo puedo encontrar a ben y para eso me
voy a fijar en uno de estos puntos es
decir me voy a fijar en la información
que tengo y voy a usar este punto aunque
puede usar también este otro sin embargo
lo importante es tomarme uno de esos dos
puntos y me voy a tomar este de aquí y
dice cuando x vale menos uno lleva de
seis entonces 6 es igual a menos cinco
tercios por menos uno es el valor de x
más ven estoy situado en este punto
donde sabemos que estamos en nuestra
recta y entonces pues lo único que hay
que hacer es resolver para ver es decir
buscar la b que satisfaga esta ecuación
y bueno me queda 6 es igual a menos 1
por 5 tercios que son 5 tercios
positivos más ven y para despejar a ver
lo que ves es restar menos 5 tercios de
ambos lados de la ecuación menos cinco
tercios por aquí menos cinco tercios por
acá y entonces que me va a quedar 6
menos 5 tercios esto cuánto es bueno voy
a ponerlo por acá para que sea mucho más
fácil resolverlo
6 - 5 tercios lo voy a escribir aquí
arriba 6 menos 5 tensión es exactamente
lo mismo y el 6 lo voy a convertir en
tercios
6 es 18 tercios menos 5 tercios esto es
igual a 13 tercios y ya tengo mi
denominador común 13 tercios y por lo
tanto me vale 13 tercios 13 tercios
porque estos dos se cancelan y del lado
derecho solamente me queda a 20 verbal
de 13 tercios y entonces ya pueden
sustituir el valor de b en esta ecuación
que tengo que arriba y es igual a menos
5 tercios de x menos 5 tercios de x más
ven pero b es 13 tercios más 13 tercios
y bueno esto lo podemos escribir en
forma mixta 13 tercios es lo mismo que
cuatro enteros un tercio es decir en
donde cortamos al eje de las 10 es el
punto 0,13 tercios o 0,4 enteros un
tercio que es este de aquí y además la
pendiente nos dice que tenemos menos
cinco tercios claramente se nota que es
una recta que va hacia abajo por lo
tanto tenemos una pendiente negativa y
esto vista de su forma mixta es lo mismo
que un entero dos tercios es decir que
por cada cambio en x hay un cambio de un
entero con dos tercios en y
por cada unidad de cambio en x entonces
vamos a cambiar un entero dos tercios en
james hacia abajo y ya está aquí tenemos
la solución de este problema que espero
que te haya sido bastante útil